[Music]
we all showed up in costume together
I've only had a few fans freak out
moments but that was like huge seeing
you I was just like I'd walk around you
kind of like checking you out so weird
on my own okay I cannot believe I'm
staying next to Batman just like a bat I
dig it
how many costumes have you had in the
last three movies and which one was the
worst there's like a Batman bat suit and
then there's like a tactical suit then
that one was a bit tighter than warmer I
also put some glasses on because I had a
little bit of flesh showing I can
breathe and they're like let's close
that there you were covered that was
smooth sailing I had pajamas on the
entire time all of those things like
when you see rain at the Jamis my suits
40 pounds you have to get screwed into
yours play like 20 pounds right you got
nothing on and I'm just dancing around
you can see the change in his pocket
yeah hey everybody they're dropping new
Justice League promos and I know I even
just did that Rick and Morty finale
video there's a Rick and Morty Easter
egg in all this Justice League which is
pretty funny I've also got a flash
season 4 promo that I'll break down in a
second but it's slightly unrelated to
the Justice League suits so I wanted to
do that first but just a reminder even
though this is mostly Justice League
stuff that the flash season 4 is
starting next week so be sure to
subscribe to get everything
there'll be more separate trailers for
all that stuff coming to that I'll
explain at the end of the video along
with flash ring giveaway stuff but I
love the way they make fun of all their
old costumes like one woman is basically
saying she's walking around naked
cyborg talks about walking around in his
underpants for the entire movie and then
Batman I was surprised that Ben Affleck
was saying that the Justice League
costume was a little more uncomfortable
than his giant tank suit that he wore
during Batman V Superman because you
think that that would take a lot more
time to put on but just like the flash
has to have all the little bits of his
costume bolted on separately I think
that's the same situation with Batman's
tactical suit so this promo doesn't
really do it justice this is a much
better high-res behind-the-scenes
picture it gives you a sense for how
much detail goes into some of these
costumes like this isn't the only
costume that he's wearing in the movie
but he's going from his more lightweight
costume that he wore during Batman V
Superman and Suicide Squad
to this once they start armoring up for
Steppenwolf like that's what the flying
box is all about to is that he's like
really stepping up his game they don't
talk a whole lot about the flash costume
but if you've seen the high-res pictures
of it too you can see how all the wires
stretched from different parts of it
that's so that it'll actually stay
together like those wires are literally
holding the pieces of his costume
together because when he moves so fast I
guess they just flew off in the original
versions of the costume and he just been
refining that as he's been learning
about his abilities like you look at
this behind the scenes lab picture here
this is actually really beautiful so you
can see based on the costume that he's
wearing this is from somewhere in the
scene where Bruce Wayne comes to meet
him but you can see all these digital
readouts in the backgrounds so it looks
like he's trying to quantify his speed
trying to learn more about the Speed
Force this is still a pretty early
version of the flash they haven't said
exactly how long he's had his abilities
but you can see down here that he's got
a picture of his hero who's Nikola Tesla
and he has some Rick and Morty on one of
the screens in the background the
episode that he's watching is the
needful things one where they both get
roided-up and then beat the crap out of
the devil at the end
[Applause]
why because sometimes what you really
need is for someone else to pay a
horrible price I wonder if it's Zack
Snyder or one of the production
designers that's a fan of Rick and Morty
or maybe it's Ezra Miller you always
wonder when they're little bits like
that from the real world that bleed into
the background like did somebody just do
that for fun or is somebody really high
up in the decision-making chain a huge
Rick and Morty fan and then you wonder
did they actually have to call Dan
Harmon a Justin roiland to get
permission for that like hey would you
be cool if we put this in our giant
Justice League movie they haven't
changed Wonder Woman's costume too much
but they have done a lot of
post-processing just to tune the colors
way up so compare this clip of her and
Batman vs Superman with the costume on
with this clip from the recent Justice
League trailer they've brightened a lot
of the colors in general just the color
tone of the film itself but that's just
sort of in keeping with the themes of
the film like things are going to get
brighter and obviously Superman will
come back and they've even been talking
about how his costumes color has changed
just a little bit too just to make it a
little bit brighter shade of blue in red
there are all kinds of black suit rumors
that are swirling around people are
saying that you know because this hat is
black and it talks about a black suit
that he wears in the Kryptonian
regeneration chamber that he might
actually have that in the film but just
remember that not all of the
merchandising stuff makes it into the
film so this could be misleading I think
that's been the lesson of the last
couple of years is that like they have a
bunch of toys that they want to sell
with the film so that the company can
make a lot of money so they'll have a
whole bunch of stuff like they had a
spider mobile for spider-man homecoming
there was no spider mobile in that movie
moving into the flash season forth they
released a parody trailer for big belly
burger so I'll just play this it just
meant to be a funny ad with all the
different actors from the different
shows
[Music]
you've only got one belly you don't have
to tell me that so why not treated right
I'm starving
here's a big belly burger at big belly
burger we put our best ingredients into
our burgers that's what I'm talking
about so you can put the best burgers
into your belly so this one has the
triple sec that's for you thank you
go ahead dig in it's kind of comforting
to know that no matter what city you go
to big belly burger is always going to
taste like big belly burger me full of
grease and salt hot those were the
secret ingredients well no ma'am quite
the opposite
even superheroes eat here for the super
quality palate now we go get a big belly
burger
there better be curly fries in there big
belly burger now serve in Star City and
Central City coming soon to National
City
[Music]
if you don't remember they actually had
a big belly burger standing set during
arrow season one they would go hang out
there every couple of episodes but then
they took it down and then it became a
big thing during the flash season one
and a little bit during season two and
now it really just gets an offhanded
name-drop every once in a while the
flash synopsis describes a new villain
that's sort of an amalgam from the
comics so it just reads the title is
mixed signals in the description just
reads Barry has his hands full when he
takes on a dangerous meta who can
control technology while also
confronting an obstacle in his personal
life the ramifications of abandoning
iris for six months to balance the Speed
Force meanwhile [ __ ] breaches in for a
date with Cisco but she gets annoyed
when his work keeps them apart so the
Ramsay deccan character that's going to
be the villain of the episode isn't
somebody directly out of the comics but
I think he's a version of Ramsey Murdock
who's connected to Morgan edge who's a
villain on Supergirl this season like
Morgan edge is the big villain of
Supergirl season 3 Ramsey Murdock just
has the ability to transfer his psychic
energy to objects but the way they're
using him on the flash TV show is is
more of a techno path so you can see how
they're working their way up to the
thinker if you know how the thinker's
powers work like how he can control
technology they're basically giving us a
setup villain to explain some big
concepts that will be a bigger deal
later this season so it's like oh hey
you know this is how this works so that
when they do something really big with
that later on people aren't super
confused so let me know what you think
about all this and actually you know
speaking of the Justice League costumes
we have the new future flash costume
although technically it's just called
the flash costume now that Grant Gustin
wears what do you think of it now that
we have like a nice shiny high-res
picture of it the first half of the
season sounds like it's gonna be really
crazy arrow is gonna have a legit
awesome first half of the season to just
based on all the stuff they've teased
out especially with Deathstroke and
they've already been shooting the
crossover episodes so I'll post some
more of that as it drops but there'll be
more trailers for this coming up so
there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway
you have to do to enter just be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
congratulations to Diamond spider
productions you the winner from the last
video please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details you can click here for
my Rick and Morty finale video and you
can click here for new flash season 4
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight